ces trois fois mais j'en ai déjà ses
mains mdr
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
jean de la
à voir
si votre ventre ah non c'est non
à évaluer mais c'est que ses cheveux
mais faux cheveux alors à thala si je
peux me permettre
j'ai peur que si jean racheter non mais
non après un très très négative vendredi
qu'un travail soit pas une once est pas
là et là tout flamme la tour nord
ouais la wla tous ces sources qui me
disent amen
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais je crois qu'il faut que je le fasse
ici et là sur mathieu norman a précisé
que c'est mon métier
n'en faites le sur isabelle du coup tu
vaux johnny on est en atelier coiffure
oh la la c'est bien donc c'est très très
bien mais ça m'a fallu temps c'est pas
mal
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non c'est bon c'est la casse et les 7 en
valeur
tu es bien pour le ps